An ideal solution would be semantic, and it would
validate properly. It wouldn't require Java Script or a
server configuration, necessarily. It would only load one copy
of the image, and it would work across all
browsers, and be accessible. Unfortunately, that solution doesn't exist
today. There's several solutions under discussion. Right now, it
looks like the end solution will be some version
of the picture element. Hopefully, this will be hashed
out in the relatively near future, so stay tuned to
the standards community for more. There's a link to the
Responsive Images Community Group in the Instructor Notes. In the
meantime, though, let's take a look at some other solutions.